good afternoon everyone so this
presentation came about when Peter came
to the Arts Library one day and was
looking for some images of magazine
covers and as we often do in the arts
library we started in print then we
started talking about digital
subscriptions and what that might mean
and I said well you know we have the
vogue archive and he didn't but he does
now so that led to the project that
we're gonna be talking about today so
since the 1890s the library has been
subscribing to and preserving the print
edition of Vogue magazine which started
publishing in 1892
so you see here an image of many just a
tiny percentage of our bound volumes of
this journal and in a few years ago
ProQuest and Conde Nast got together and
made it a digital archive so and this is
now available through with the library
are this involved a lot of different
people in the library our licensing
librarian helped us get the perpetual
access license after our selectors
decided to purchase this for the library
and our digital preservation librarian
is going to make sure that we have
access to this in perpetuity now that we
have all six terabytes of data through
that perpetual access license and our
digital humanities librarian of course
is going to help us dig into the data so
it's it's interesting to know that this
is the the result of lots of different
library people coming together and that
this becomes something that's accessible
through the library collection that we
have access to to do some great digital
humanities work so zooming out just a
bit why why would we met mine magazine
archives in particular so in contrast to
novels magazine data is very specific
it's very date specific so you have the
correlation between the publication date
and the date of the material which isn't
always true otherwise and so it and many
magazines are published over several
decades like Vogue or time or National
Geographic and they're also prime
materials for digitization projects so
we have not only vendor-supplied things
like this vogue through ProQuest and
Conde Nast but things like Gale cengage
Liberty magazine and also things like
the Blue Mountain project that's coming
out of Princeton University so they're
digitizing avant-garde journals there
and so something like Vogue is a general
interest magazine that can capture the
look and feel of an era very well and
vogue is particularly interesting for
that purpose Vogue has been continuously
published since 1892 and now that it's a
digital archive we can actually think of
it as big data so we can think of it as
four hundred forty thousand units its
foreign over four hundred forty thousand
pages twenty seven hundred issues or
however you want to view it it is an
immense amount of data over a century of
publishing but more important for
research is the way that the archive is
actually structured so previous
electronic access to Vogue before this
archive a few years ago was text only
which strikes horror into the hearts of
art librarians everywhere but you had
only text access there were no images of
ads or images of anything and so now
thanks to this archive we have images we
have advertisements and they're all
marked up as such so we can use that
there ocr'd the full pages are not just
images of pages but also marked up as
through XML and ocr'd we can search the
text we have lots of metadata as I'll
talk about in a second so in case you
haven't seen it this is what the
interface looks like through ProQuest if
you go through the library homepage and
access this database so this is a sample
search of Irving Penn and it comes up
with 2,350 results so you it's just a
keyword search of him so the reason that
that works is because it's all marked up
by photographers models designers etc so
it's structured in a way that we can do
this kind of search but looking at this
interface this is a sort of preliminary
interface for ProQuest it inspired us to
think about what else we might be able
to do with this kind of data so this is
what it looks like inside the innards of
the Vogue archive the XML markup so this
is an advertisement from May 1950 from
Saks
Fifth Avenue and this is what is
underpinning the the great things that
we're able to do with this data so if
you read at Vogue for eight hours a day
it would take you three years to read
every issue of Vogue which sounds pretty
good to me
but we've already given you some
statistics about the sheer amount of
data that is so what do we do the that's
it presents the larger question of
knowing the archive well enough to know
what's in it so I've looked at a lot of
Irving Penn photographs over the years
but I was still surprised to see how
much is in the vogue archive and see
what he photographed for Vogue the
question is how do you even form a smart
keyword query if you don't know what the
archive contains and how would any
researcher know what they might do with
this archive so Peters going to outline
some strategies of using digital
humanities two methods to get at that
thank you
so in an archive this large or really in
any archive this large whether it's the
Google Books corpus of 20 million
volumes or all of the magazine newspaper
articles from the Yale Daily News the
challenge is is that it's as Lindsay
mentioned you almost have to know what's
in it to know what to look for so this
becomes the paradox of the bore Jian map
where your mental map of the corpus
might be just as large as all those
bound volumes that we just saw on the
shelf so one potential way around this
paradox is to let latent patterns in the
data provide user interface affordances
in order to expose some of the things
that are going on in these four hundred
and forty thousand pages the way we get
at some of this latent structure is
unfortunately for a literature person
like myself through statistics and math
and so there are algorithms that can
help us surface these latent patterns
but what's important and good for a
literature person like myself is that
humans are still involved in
interpreting the results of these
algorithms we want to have computers do
with they're really good at which is do
math really quickly we want to have
humanists responsible for the
interpretation of any kind of
algorithmic Missouri results robots for
Speed humans for in evaluation and
interpretation and we want to tell you
about two different ways you might think
about this archive or really any kind of
visual and textual archive of this scale
so we're going to tell you two stories
today we're going to tell you a vision
story ways of making sense of all of the
images in vogue over time and then we're
going to tell you a textual story ways
of making sense of themes that might be
going on in vogue over all these tens of
thousands of pages and we're gonna start
with the visual first we're going to
talk a little bit about some ways that
we've made the covers of Vogue
accessible in a kind of web environment
for looking at this enormous corpus now
the covers are obviously just a fraction
of the images that are in the vogue
archive but this one image bears a kind
of indexical relationship to the
magazine that comes behind it right when
any magazine is on a newsstand it's
trying to attract you to buy that
magazine with its cover with the words
on this cover and the colors and the
pictures on its cover so it's kind of an
interesting reason for thinking about
covers as a kind of index to the actual
magazine itself so what we did is an
experiment to build a relational
database with all of the covers or
thumbnails of all the covers in this
with a lot of explicit metadata we knew
about the covers for example when were
the covers produced who was the editor
at that time and who was the
photographer or the illustrator who
contributed to that design so we're
going to show you now this is vogue over
time we start in August 2013 and
depending on how fast I scroll without
making emotion sick I can take you back
in time to the 1980s at which the covers
looked very different I can go back in
time a long way and we can hit times
when the covers were more Illustrated
and if I go back far enough actually
color disappears and we start looking at
black and white covers that's simple
enough to understand but as I mentioned
before the vogue archive which was
digitized by ProQuest contains an
amazing amount of explicit metadata
about all of the images so I can select
only the covers that were designed by
Irving Penn and then I can sort those
covers by the editor-in-chief at that
time and group them by the editor so now
I can see what was curving pens designs
look like underneath Anna Wintour verses
underneath Dianna Vreeland verses
underneath Edna Woolman chase it's the
same artist but what's changed is the is
the editors and we can do that for all
of the people here so this is just a way
of being able to move explicit metadata
about the covers to kind of surf through
an archive of magazine covers over time
now that's interesting
and we think that's a good way to start
it's a way of using kind of interesting
facts that we know about the archive but
there are some facts that aren't
immediately obvious by looking at the
date of a magazine or the name of the
editor on the on the masthead and so we
wanted to move a little beyond explicit
metadata and go and extract some latent
data from the images themselves and we
did this using a slightly different tool
which I'm going to show you on the
screen now so what we're looking at now
is thousands of covers from vogue that
have had their color analyzed and we've
extracted the means hue saturation and
luminance from these images as well as
the proportional percent of red green or
blue color so right now I'm looking at a
particular vision of the ARRA covers
arranged by their saturation but I can
switch one of these access to luminance
what you can see is darker images on the
left whiter images on the right and the
blue level blue things at top not so
blue things at the bottom I can change
this to saturation and so we can still
be arranging blue on the axis and I can
see less saturated things on one side
and others on the other so this is just
a kind of way of thinking about on image
sort of color metrics that were able to
extract from the images and use that as
kind of navigation patterns through the
archive